all due respect to donnie deutsch now
this is one good looking guest host
game is a foot sports fans welcome to
what is effectively the first day of the
general election hopper we have a lot to
cover on tonight's show but let's begin
with today's dueling speeches between
donald j trump billionaire and hillary r
clinton multi-millionaire both delivered
pretty formal campaign speeches to their
respective bases this afternoon trump
spoke to a conservative audience at the
annual faith and freedom conference in
washington d.c his first public event
since that stilted teleprompter speech
on tuesday night
that happened right after clinton
addressed members of the planned
parenthood action fund less than a mile
away her first public appearance since
those big endorsements from president
obama vice president joe biden and
elizabeth warren yesterday trump hit
clinton clinton hit trump let's go to
the tape
when donald trump says let's make
america great again
that is code for
let's take
america backward hillary clinton or as i
call her crooked hillary clinton
refuses to even say the words radical
islam this alone makes her unfit to be
president anyone who wants to defund
planned parenthood
and wipe out safe legal abortion has no
idea what's best for women she'll
appoint radical judges who will
legislate from the bench overriding
congress and will i'll tell you the will
of the people will mean nothing nothing
this is a man who has called women pigs
dogs
and disgusting
animals of hard to imagine counting on
him to respect our fundamental rights
her policies will be a crushing blow to
all poor people in this country
all right so this is coming off a pretty
stellar week for hillary clinton in one
of the worst weeks or two for trump
but for the moment mike let's try to
strip away that context and just judge
these speeches on their own merits we
will expect to see a lot more of what we
just saw over the course of the months
ahead
on this first day of the general
election who had the better day
hillary clinton had the better day
because she's had the better week but
donald trump if you watch that speech
today he is picked up the pace a bit
with the teleprompters he's doing a
little bit better reading the speech
from the teleprompter the speech i
thought
included all sorts of extraneous
subjects that he was throwing in there
i don't know why he did that but at the
end of the day it gets back to the point
that you've discussed endlessly there is
no campaign there there is just donald
trump yeah it's true i thought you know
that um that i've always found it's
strange that uh donald trump has uh the
level of support he has among uh
religious uh republicans given the fact
that it's the one place where it seems
shakiest to me there's no sense the
sense that donald trump has something in
common with born again or evangelicals
does not strike me as particularly
plausible i will say i thought hillary
clinton was very good today i thought
trump if only because he's had such a
horrible two weeks and he managed to
give that speech today and do
behave like a somewhat normal candidate
you know reading from the script
making his hits as expected it was
actually pretty good it was maybe even a
little bit better day for trump just
because his week was previous
so bad i mean because of the level of
expectation yes the level of
expectations right but don't you think
that part of trump's appeal to the
evangelicals and it is there we've seen
that we've seen we've witnessed it
through the primaries is because of what
he did today he shows up and he gives
this strong man speech attacking hillary
clinton and his points are all about
strength and i'll protect the country
and they that appeals to evangelicals as
well as a whole host of people in the
primaries yeah that's that's yes that's
true
nobody loves talking about polls more
than donald trump but we didn't hear him
say much today about the newest national
survey by fox news it shows trump
trailing hillary clinton in the general
election match up 42 percent to 39
percent that's a six point drop from a
month ago for the presumptive republican
nominee trump's strength of republicans
and among men seems still to be growing
but this poll shows a 12-point swing in
clinton's direction among independents
since mid-may john it's important to
know that this poll was in the field
before those big clinton endorsements
yesterday so she's
you know probably get an even bigger
bump in the in the coming days how
worried do you think the trump campaign
as it exists whatever the campaign is
should they be more worried than they
seem to be well i think that the point
you make is the relevant point mike we
are going to see hillary clinton as she
has with astonishing speed move to
starting start unifying the democratic
party she's going to see a lift the
traditional lift she gets she's now the
perspective of the presumptive nominee
got a lot of people behind her bernie
sanders is falling in line she's going
to get a big lift but i have to say if
i'm donald trump looking at the
just the overall the six-point drop
given how horrible the last couple weeks
had been for him he might have expected
it to be worse than what he's seen today
he might i think wrongly but he might be
looking at those numbers saying i only
dropped six points after all of that i
can make that up well i don't disagree
with it because donald trump is donald
trump i mean he sees he sees bright
lights and everything
but
anyone around him who has his ear and i
don't know that is anyone i would think
they would be very worried because you
can sense just anecdotally sort of a
mini collapse within that campaign right
now and then in a few weeks prior to the
democrat convention republican
convention he is going to be set in
cement by the democratic campaign
against him and look at that number with
independence is is the worrying thing
that's the thing if you're trump's
people or trump and you're really
focused on this poll that's thing you're
most worried about because his strength
with independence has been a large part
of why he's been able to keep so far be
kind of neck and neck with clinton if
the bottom falls out among independent
voters available voters not partisan
democrats not partisan republicans if
the bottom falls out there he has no
chance to ever be hillary clinton and
that at least right now seems to be
what's happening well yeah and i i don't
think the trump campaign people have
facted into the equation that there
aren't enough white men in america to
elect him president united states if
that is what he's dependent white men
are your specialty those are your people
well look at me claire i mean the latest
man i've ever seen you know something
about white men but there's not enough
of you out there that you're saying the
conservative version of you correct yeah
i mean look the demographics are stacked
against them and that's why i say you
know with these independent voters um
you know they're they've been attracted
to trump all along what they what this
poll suggests is that independent voters
have been affected in a significant way
by all of the negative headlines and the
controversy and trump's racist comments
and that is again real reason for worry
for him all right hillary clinton
unveiled her all-star lineup of
democratic surrogates last night what it
means for your 2016 fantasy league right
after this quick commercial break
so
today at her home in washington d.c
hillary clinton huddled with
massachusetts senator elizabeth warren
the newest high-profile recruit of
clinton's presidential campaign team but
after that big day of endorsements
yesterday warren is just one heavy
hitter in a murderous row of new
democratic surrogates who are stepping
up to the 2016 election plate and
swinging for the fence
in this already
vastly overextended baseball metaphor
clinton's lineup includes warren and
vice president joe biden who both spoke
at the american constitution society's
convention last night and of course
hitting the cleanup spot is president
barack obama whose appearance on the
tonight show with jimmy fallon aired
last night so let's take a look at the
replay
donald trump
is a loud nasty thin-skinned fraud who
has never risked anything for anyone and
who serves no one but himself
i find donald trump's
conduct in this regard
reprehensible a dangerous attack and a
vital pillar of democracy the
independent judiciary by threats of
intimidation and undercutting the
legitimacy of a judge by suggesting that
because of his heritage he's incapable
of being
fair
in addition to this it is racist
thank you congress
for spending eight years
wishing you could replace me with a
republican
or
to put it another way
how do you like me now
okay a couple of hard hits and then a
joke just to round it out all right the
strength of clinton's lineup is only
heightened by the state of the
surrogates on the republican bench to
wit after trump argued in a press
statement that his comments about judge
curiel were misconstrued ben carson
reportedly told politico this week that
trump fully recognizes that that was not
the right thing to say end quote good
old ben carson you had one job there
buddy all right mike uh
hillary clinton has had one super
surrogate her husband with her the whole
time and now she's filled out the roster
with warren and biden and obama what
roles do you think that each of those
super surrogates those three what
distinct roles do you think they will
play in her campaign as we go forward
well a couple of things it's going to be
a long time before we have a president
united states as cool as barack obama is
on the jimmy fallon stuff the other
thing is good really good on the humor
all of hillary yeah yeah all of hillary
clinton's surrogates can all hit major
league pitching to continue endlessly
this baseball metaphor uh trump's
surrogates uh he seemingly has none the
best of the surrogates that he have
happened to be his children i think
going forward the strongest surrogate
that hillary clinton has i think without
doubt will be the president of the
united states who is fully committed to
beating donald trump not just beating
donald trump but devastating donald
trump because of largely
the roots of his antipathy toward him is
i think the birth certificate for sure
100 and the suggestion that he's not
male 1 he's not an illegitimate he's not
a legitimate yeah president united
states that he was the the face for that
movement i think you've got these three
will all be a big part of the campaign
and i think as i suggested they will
play distinct roles you know elizabeth
warren is shaping up as a fiery attack
dog figure she will appeal to the
populist left uh she can take trump on
as you know with a degree of ferocity
that hillary clinton is not capable of
um
trump can mock her as pocahontas but
she's still going to be very good in
that role
biden appealing to working-class white
voters especially men who hillary
clinton has had trouble with as a
constituency group and president obama
just the authority of the office no one
is in a better position even better than
hillary clinton no one is in a position
to suggest that trump is unsuited to an
unfit to be commander in chief than the
guy who actually is commander-in-chief
right now what's interesting about
elizabeth warren at least to me and i
think to some people besides me is the
fearlessness with which she takes on
donald trump when the field of
republican candidates against donald
trump all of them were fearful of him
yeah and and none of it like look none
of those folks biden warren obama and
when bill clinton gets out there none of
them will be in any way afraid of donald
trump no he will have good days uh on
this campaign no doubt but i i don't see
a single surrogate a single surrogate
right now for donald trump there is not
one it's not just that i don't see it
there is not one who can play uh at
major league level like all of those
four people who are at the top of the
democratic surrogate
lineup i agree
speaking of trump's surrogate problem
top republicans like house speaker paul
ryan and senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell are still clearly
uncomfortable with having him as their
party's presumptive nominee but in tone
and substance the two gop leaders are
handling this hot potato in somewhat
different ways take a look at the latest
rounds of trump criticism ryan in an
interview that aired on good morning
america today and mcconnell in the
latest episode of bloomberg's masters in
politics podcast
this is something that needed to be
condemned
that comment is beyond the pale that's
not political correctness
suggesting that a person can't do their
job because of the race or ethnicity
that's not
that's not a politically incorrect thing
to do that's just a wrong thing to say
and i i hope that he gets that i believe
he walked this comment back what core
principle is more important to the party
of lincoln than standing up against
racism that's why i did that that's why
i spoke out against it and it won't be
the last time if if this continues
hopefully this won't continue it's
pretty obvious he doesn't know a lot
about
the issues you see that in the debates
in which he's participated
it's why i have argued to him publicly
and privately that he ought to use the
script more often there's nothing wrong
with having
prepared texts it indicates a level of
seriousness that i think is important to
convey
to the american people about the job
you're seeking
john mcconnell seems like he's being a
little tougher than ryan when it comes
to trump uh especially in his comments
today to bloomberg in which he basically
said he knows nothing about the issues
right we can coach him yeah uh what's
going on here well look i mean the
there's uh issues institutional issues
differences between the house and the
senate we can talk about those in a
second but mitch mcconnell is in the job
his last job you're not gonna do
anything else other than the majority
leader or maybe a minority leader if the
democrats take over the senate paul ryan
wants to be president united states and
he's looking at 2020 and the likelihood
that donald trump in his view i think
donald trump is going to lose this
election and trump is trying and ryan is
trying to figure out a way to both
protect his members
but not alienate trump voters that he
might need when he runs for president
next time around mitch mcconnell has a
reputation though as you know of being
principally a very cautious individual
right who would not tell you if your
coat were on fire no would i tell you if
your coat were on fire but it's actually
happened several times in the past my
code's been on fire i just let the damn
thing burn i said nothing yeah
what is what's going through mcconnell's
mind if you can if you can put yourself
in mcconnell's man he's basically
seeming to write donald trump off in a
sense well you know i look i think those
mcconnell is really focused i think more
than more than anything mcconnell is
focused on trying to somehow somehow
against the odds given the number of
seats that republicans are defending in
the senate she wants to keep hold of
that senate majority and to do that i
think of his calculation like a lot of
republican senators is the only way for
them to do it is to put as much distance
as possible between themselves and
donald trump and that's he's starting to
lay down markers for that right now i
think you're mitch mcconnell is going to
be running away from donald trump along
with a lot of republican senators all
election long so do you think paul
ryan's job as speaker the house leader
the titular leader of the national
republican party
the the phrase leadership and character
they both go together
what is he sacrificing in terms of his
hesitancy to really come out and say
listen this guy is not what i thought
well you tell you tell me what do you
think he's sacrificing your questions
are loaded right you seem to be
suggesting something there go right
ahead i i think i think at the end of
the day he's sacrificing a lot of his
hard-earned reputation that he has as a
smart guy who wants to broaden his
approach to politics poverty and things
like that and he's sacrificing he's in a
ridiculous position right now which is
to basically say uh
he's a racist his comments are textbook
racism and yet i still endorse him not a
great place to be all right today was
the funeral of a great great man
muhammad ali laid to rest in louisville
kentucky this afternoon
we'll talk about that special service
when we come back
it's been a week since muhammad ali
passed away at the age of 74 but the
world is still mourning today
celebrities athletes civil rights
leaders politicians including former
president bill clinton and heads of
state from as far away as turkey and
jordan gathered for the funeral of the
greatest of all time honoring legendary
boxer muhammad ali in the city of his
childhood louisville kentucky
mike i want to go
take go back
um a long time now back to 1980 long
time uh in uh in marblehead
massachusetts i believe where you uh
spent some time in the presence of ali
just take us back to that and tell us
about that moment and you wrote about it
that's why i know this happened
actually it was 36 years ago
this past wednesday
and yes muhammad ali was in
massachusetts he was going to address
the class day
on the fifth reunion for the class of
1975. it was june of 1980 their fifth
reunion at harvard at harvard and i met
him i went up to meet him in the morning
he was staying at a friend's home in
marblehead massachusetts i spent the day
with him but the most poignant and most
insightful part of the day to me was
just he and i having breakfast in this
man's home
and he spoke uh
eloquently about his lack of fear that
he didn't fear anything happening to him
because he had fought the government he
had changed his name he had given up his
title
he had given up his olympic medal all
for his belief and his commitment
he talked about i asked him at one point
you know do you worry about brain damage
you get hit so hard i was referring
specifically to the thriller in manila
fight
and he said who knows and
he said if it happens it happens but he
was just an enormously throughout his
life obviously an enormously charismatic
figure and you were kind of in awe when
you were with him and you had to sort of
fight that feeling of awe in order to
just listen to what he was saying one of
the most extraordinary things about ali
it seems to me is this is that you know
you've met presidents you've met you
know heads of state you've met uh
fortune 500 ceos met a lot of people in
the course of your journalistic career
and you like every other journalist i
know who spent time with ali and and
most other sports figures who spend time
with ali most of the celebrities
speaks of him in the same way the
biggest egos in the world i include you
here but even bigger egos than yours
were like oh my god it's just like being
in his presence was a kind of magical
experience just because of
he's the totally self-created man and
his his energy his wit um and and the
charisma that you talked about just i
literally there's no one who does not
have that kind of and not just after
he's because of his death in real time
people would say oh you know there's
just nobody nothing like him and no one
like him well this was 1980 and he was
already arguably the most famous person
in the world
and he was obviously an iconic figure of
the 20th and the 21st century
and he was involved in arguably two of
the greatest sporting events ever to
occur the rumble in the jungle and the
thriller in manila in which both men in
the ring frazier and ali almost died
that fight was held at 10 o'clock in the
morning for american television purposes
the temperature in the ring was 120
degrees and after the fight ali said he
was so prophetic he was so smart he said
we went to joe frazier and i went to
manila as champions and we came home as
old men yeah right i'm you know
yes i'm incredible those fights i mean
if you go back and watch them now on
youtube it is something and you know
it's an amazing thing the degree to
which boxing although it still exists in
our world is no longer used to be the
most important sports event you know
every celebrity the greatest writers
everybody flocked to the ring to see the
great heavyweights fight now of course
boxing still exists but it's nothing
like the kind of attraction i think
partly because of ali because the
perception right or wrong because we
don't know the answer to this that
somehow that ali's the beatings he took
was part of why he ended up with
parkinson's people believe that and i
think it's part of though of why boxing
has lost favor in our society as people
look at ali and said you know that he's
somehow even again rightly or wrongly
they see him as a vivid illustration of
just how savage the sport is and i think
the country to a large extent is kind of
turned against the sport for that reason
i absolutely agree with you and you
wonder if pro football will be next but
on ali you also wonder and the passage
of time gives us allowance to look at
this
so many people missed
the importance of his social cultural
statements in the 60s some of our
friends some of the greatest newspaper
writers of all time missed it right and
made fun of him ran him down right right
he changed his name because he was a
muslim because he came out against the
war in vietnam but he was right you know
it was interesting the day after uh he
passed away uh uh in the nba finals that
there were people who talked to lebron
james in cleveland or i think in san
francisco uh for at the in the warriors
uh at the oracle uh arena and james
pointed out that he felt like ali had
freed him to take some of the stances
that james has taken you know ali
was as important as an athlete more
important in some ways for the things he
did outside about absolutely things that
he did and you know from the moment he
decided to resist the draft he not only
became an incredibly important figure in
black culture and more broadly in the
anti-war movement but he freed athletes
to become engaged in politics in a way
that they never had before and you
suddenly had things from the 68 olympics
you know with uh with carlos you know
with the with the black power salute but
you know every on every dimension of
sports suddenly sports figures are like
hey i can i can be involved in the
broader social issues that rack the
country and you have to ask yourself
this question that obviously took great
courage it would take anyone great
courage to get in a ring and fight for
your life as muhammad ali did but today
you look at athletes and we revere many
athletes today which among them would
have the courage that he had to stand up
for himself and his beliefs yes and it
is the case that you know you i i stand
by my assertion that
he was a signal uh phenomenon in terms
of the politization of sports uh
sometimes for good sometimes for ill but
it is the case that although he freed a
lot of athletes to get involved in
politics none of them at the kind of
cost that he assumed correct none of
them assuming the kind of courage that
was required for him to do what he did
none of them paid anything like the kind
of price that he paid uh having taken
himself out of millions of dollars and
out of the prime of his career just
because he was not going to go and fight
those vietcong all right coming up we
turn again to presidential politics and
donald trump's latest controversy we'll
be right back with all of that
welcome back over the past 24 hours or
so both usa today and the wall street
journal published similar investigations
into past lawsuits against donald j
trump and his company
the stories zero in on small businesses
employees and vendors who over the years
according to the stories sued trump for
not getting full payment for their
services
defending his business dealings trump
told the wall street journal quote i
love to hold back and negotiate when
people don't do good work
end quote he also told usa today quote
let's say that they do a good job they
do a job that's not good or a job they
didn't finish or a job that was way way
late i'll deduct from their contract
absolutely end quote that's what the
country should be doing that's what the
country should be doing that's a further
extension of that quote joining us now
to unpack these two stories are two of
the reporters behind them alexander
alexandra brazan from the wall street
journal joins us from la and nick pensen
stadler of usa today who joins us from
denver you guys thanks for being here uh
alexander let me start with you um we're
just just
give us both these stories are have been
gotten a lot of attention today just
give me first uh an overview of the most
important things that you found
in reporting this piece
yeah what we found is that there were a
number of people who had been doing work
for donald trump or his companies things
like drapery making curtains or
selling chandeliers and they had
not had a hard time getting paid trump
had sued them or they had had to sue
trump to in order to try to get paid and
we also found that there was uh there
were people from the trump organization
who had worked for donald trump over the
years who had said that this was really
kind of a philosophy of the company that
the com you know nowadays the company
says that's not true um but that you
know if you can pay 75 percent of what
you owe pay 75 that that's what we had
right
right nick let me ask you um uh sort of
the same question um both these stories
are very obviously consistent to some
extent overlapping i think the thing
that was striking about uh your piece
the usa today piece is just the sheer
volume that you guys documented like
hundreds of instances of the kind of
thing that alexander is talking about so
give us again a sense of what uh what
you guys found in your investigation
right so it really broke down into
contractors and these vendors who had to
sue um so those are all the civil
litigation that you can find across the
country and then these labor cases so
there are complaints that go to the
labor department and then ultimately you
know end up in in court also for workers
and bartenders and servers who don't get
paid for overtime or for what they're
owed
alexandra in picking up on that line of
thought that nick just mentioned did you
find in the in the journal report that
small vendors uh people in business for
themselves i mean if their payment is
delayed beyond 30 days or
60 days in some cases here that they
find themselves in in real economic
trouble as a small business and trump is
causing this trouble
i did find that with some people i mean
the people who had there were people who
talked about it getting delayed 60 70
days which you know
trump said oh is that a lot of time but
first for these people that that did
happen to it was a problem for them and
they did tell me that that that you know
they had trouble they had to pay their
vendors and their employees so it was a
problem for people
you know nick it's a funny human nature
being what it is and the economy being
the way it is and reading your story i
get a sense from some of the people that
you were reporting on some of the small
business owners that you were talking to
they probably all realize to their shock
and amazement that it's much easier for
donald trump to owe a bank a hundred
million dollars than for them to owe
another one of their sub vendors 750
dollars not being able to repay it that
puts them in real trouble
right and i mean we also saw these this
huge variety in you know
final bills that were 30 000 or even
less than that and these huge contracts
that were in the millions um and and the
trump organization many times would
treat them the same way where they would
try to negotiate or on the final payment
they would say we know we've paid enough
already and we're not going to give you
this last installment uh but we'll still
let you work for us in the future uh to
the shock of many of these small-time
vendors who would say you know i'm not
going to work with these guys ever again
nick let me stay with you and let me ask
you this question this is a rough and
tumble business most of the businesses
that trump's involved with there's a lot
of people who do i play a lot of
hardball right so what do you say to the
pushback that that is like yes
trump the the the allegations are what
they are but that this is common
practice among uh people who do business
and the kinds of businesses that trump
uh deals in just just you know it's
tough sometimes rough sometimes people
throw sharp elbows but it's par for the
course
right and i mean ultimately that's up
for for our readers and voters to judge
um the thing we've really thought about
is
um you know we we don't have a business
record for hillary clinton to judge but
we do have
a you know business record for donald
trump and vice versa with hillary and
you know not owning a business so we
have to judge what we have
and uh anything less than a stellar
record in either of those we think is
fair game to scrutinize and to to pick
apart alexander just tell me about you
know that trump responded to both these
stories including yours um by basically
saying you know yeah i sort of did this
stuff and and actually it's got a smart
business um
was that the extent of their of their
response i mean there are a lot of
allegations uh in your piece um is that
was that was there a kind of a terse uh
response or was there a more thorough
going pushback on the things that you
reported
there was some pushback i mean i think
there was a push back on the premise of
the story saying you know to to the
point you're speaking on earlier to this
idea that you know these are just uh
you're picking out a few cases we have
lots of people that we work with who you
know
who who want to be our vendors and have
had good experiences and and so we spoke
with many of them um and and we included
some of that in the story but we also
think that it's it's fair game to uh
point to the people that did not have
good experiences all right working for
trump all right alexander burzin nick
penzen stadler
thank you for your work and for being on
the show up next espn's new epic
documentary series about o.j simpson it
has a lot of people talking i'll show
you my interview with the director of
that series in just a moment if you're
watching us in washington dc though
please keep in mind that you can also
listen to us on the radio radio at
bloomberg 99.1 f m we'll be right back
espn is set to release what it's calling
it's
most ambitious project to date
as part of the network's 30 for 30
documentary brand oj made in america is
a five-part doc series that dives deep
into the life and career of football
hall of famer o.j simpson as well as the
complex social and racial backdrop for
the juices landmark murder trial the
first episode airs saturday that's
tomorrow at 9 00 pm eastern on abc
with subsequent episodes running on espn
all of next week the other day i sat
down here at bloomberg headquarters in
gotham city with the director of that
series ezra edelman and asked him what
it was like to make a film this
political for the total sports network
espn at some point came to you and said
make a long-form doc and we wanted to be
on o.j simpson right correct um you were
not thrilled by that topic initially
right what turned you around
uh the
idea that they came to me with this
larger canvas which was we want to do
five hours
and as soon as i thought it started
thinking about the five hours part of it
what i was reluctant to do
was a story about his guilt or innocence
or a regurgitation of the trial so as
soon as it happened that i realized that
i had
a bigger canvas to work with that i said
oh i can tell a story about l.a about
race in america and race in los angeles
about who oj was from a racial and
identity standpoint story about the lapd
story about all these things that
actually i am interested in and that i
feel like have been overlooked in
explaining the events of 94.95 what were
the threads in it that
i mean to me race was obviously going to
be a huge threat right because of the
nature of how the trial unfolded what
happened as the as the public spectacle
of o.j was what were the other threads
that you didn't necessarily think would
be big parts of it that became big parts
of it and ended up engrossing you and
and thereby becoming big parts of the of
the work um you're right race was the
predominant theme but i'd say the sub
theme initially was celebrity it was
impossible to reduce this to this is a
story about one thing and so whether
it's race celebrity gender masculinity
the criminal justice system policing
whatever it is there's such an
interconnectedness to all these things
that it's impossible to sort of leave
them you know off the table and so
that's what i sort of realized it's
about everything and not just about one
thing yeah the specificity of the racial
experience the black experience in los
angeles the the history of policing in
l.a as you mentioned why is that
specificity so important to
understanding what happened with oj as
opposed to just the broader racial
canvas of america in the early to mid
1990s because the entire
trial was was framed no pun intended
upon whether
this black icon
was sort of treated unfairly by the
police whether evidence was planted
whether he was framed that was the
explanation the entire defense was about
look at who the lapd has been in our
city for the past 50 years look at what
they do to black people and then when
you start to parse who oj is
and sort of the choices he made
the
advantages that he had as an athlete and
as a celebrity where he lived there was
this inherent irony to that defense um
being connected to this man and then
when you think of the fact that oh sure
we grew up in a time and i did i was in
high school when rodney king happened
that the way the trial has been
discussed is oh this is just payback for
rodney king when people wanted to sort
of reduce the jurors decisions to that
and it was like well yes rodney king was
beaten in 1991 the riots happened in 92.
but there was this history consistently
with these incidents that went back 30
and 40 years that
were these hallmark incidents that
people in los angeles would continually
bring up to me that i realized that it
was such a deeper reservoir of of
frustration
and tension that needed to be explored
and that really was what was drawn upon
by the defense more so than just look
what happened two years ago right so
look what happened 40 years ago two
things that you know that i that really
stuck out for me one
incredible footage of al callings
oj's best friend most staunch loyal
defender
at nicole simpson's brown simpsons um
memorial service giving a tearful uh
farewell to her and the other oj simpson
after the acquittal coming back to his
house and watching the
the coverage on television and yelling
at the television set so
i mean how did you pull that off we got
very fortunate in terms of having access
to material that someone had archived
someone was there that day and shot in
the house and i mean i don't know that
if anyone had ever seen it i've never
seen it yeah and so it's just very
fortunate and the wedding footage which
is incredible the wedding of o.j and
nicole's wedding
you know there was a huge debate
obviously in the country about about
guilt or innocence and obviously the
most striking fact about it was the fact
that you know vast majority of
african-americans thought that he was
innocent vast majority of white
americans thought that he was guilty i
think that's probably still true today
um although generation i think you would
find by the way that that percentage of
black americans who think he's innocent
is much smaller than it was in 1995. so
as general as generations have passed
younger african-americans are more ready
to accept the notion that he was not
framed and that in fact he was guilty oh
i think it's not just that i think it's
two things it's the result of the civil
trial where he was found responsible for
the deaths of them and where additional
evidence came out like the bruno magle
shoes that he was wearing so it was
proven that he was wearing the shoes
that were you know encased in that
bloody footprints at the scene so that's
damning and secondly like when you look
at sort of what happened to him in this
20-year period and where he ended up it
sort of spoke to a sort of
obviously there is a a level to which
none of us can understand after going
through that period what it does to a
person whether he did it or didn't do it
and sort of how crazy that makes you but
let's just say that he didn't exactly go
to the straight and narrow path and so i
think that might have led certain people
to be less forgiving towards him as a
character and less forgiving towards the
idea of him being innocent when they see
where he ended up something i really
admire in in people who are doing
non-fiction storytelling is basically
trying to say all of these perspectives
have a certain kind of validity right
this is not a polemic right at the same
time you know you do come
to a sense that there is a case to be
made that
o.j simpson was almost certainly guilty
and yet in some way the verdict wasn't
back justice in a certain larger sense i
don't know that i would go so far as to
say the verdict itself was justice but i
would argue maybe that the verdict was
just right within the framework of what
happened in terms of what the
prosecution did or didn't do with having
a police detective at the center of an
investigation who was proven to have
perjured himself during the course of
that trial with having an incident in
court where yes literally the bloody
glove of the murderer did not fit the
apparent murderer there were enough
instances of reasonable doubt
that i understand why a juror would have
voted the way they voted to acquit him
and so in that way regardless of the
actual factual evidence including the
dna evidence linking o.j to that crime
yes there is a both hand universe where
you could look at the film and say i
believe he's guilty and i also believe
he should have gotten off well and also
that there's this larger thing going on
in terms of a kind of justice kind of
that there's a way in which the verdict
was striking a blow in some sense for
racial justice in in the city given the
long history that you can see why people
believe that and at least understand
where they're coming from and i want
people to understand that i don't want
people to sort of watch something be
like i wanted that too or i believe but
it's like if if there's a level of
empathy that people come to as people
arrive at after having watched this
whether you're a white person who'd
never thought about incidents of race
and you were wondering why the hell were
all these people celebrating and now you
watch this and emotionally connected
with these series of injustices over the
course of four decades and you go well i
get that
i understand you looked at i imagine
hundreds of hours of footage thought
about this insanely intensely all
consumingly for a couple years of your
life right and now you're going to be
talking about o.j simpson for the next
who knows how long depending on how
successful this whole venture is
what's the takeaway for you what do you
what do you say to people what do you
learn about o.j simpson what does oj
simpson mean
you know the one thing i can say is that
i was taken by oj like everybody else
as a kid growing up you know as an
athlete as a celebrity
but it's really hard when you then spend
this much time
examining somebody and the things that
he
was even on the record having done
uh and not coming away with sort of a
general feeling of
well disgust
to call it just to say yeah and so that
and that made it very difficult because
by the way i also had a real desire to
be fair to him in this story as well and
so but it's hard to ignore
all the things that that took place so
it's interesting in the context of our
earlier conversation muhammad ali
one of the most famous people on the
planet maybe the most as you said
consummate uh black is beautiful black
pride uh
o.j simpson also one of the most famous
athletes in america in roughly sum of
the same time frame who tried to
basically make himself into a raceless
figure and yet race was the dominant
late motif of the trial well race is
still the dominant factor in the life of
american politics and american culture
is something you know these ridiculous
assertions by various public people it's
time to have a conversation about race
we're never going to have that
conversation in this country an honest
conversation well we're certainly never
going to be able to move past it is like
it is so deeply embedded in the history
and the institutions of our country uh
and with some really profound injustices
we will never be post racial that film
could well win an oscar i think it could
win an oscar it's an incredible movie
it's seven and a half hours long and
there's not a moment in it not a moment
where you think i'm bored uh this is
turning me off let's pass forward
through not the single moment um
watch it
our thanks to the man who made it ezra
edelman and his whole team espn's oj
made in america as i said before
premieres tomorrow saturday at 9pm
eastern on abc when we come back more of
what mitch mcconnell said about donald
trump on bloomberg's masters and
politics podcast right after this
the choice for many americans is not a
happy choice but this is the choice do
we want four more years just like the
last eight
or do we want to go in a different
direction
for all of his obvious shortcomings
donald trump is certainly a different
director and so i'm comfortable
supporting him i think he'd have a much
better chance of winning
if he would
quit making so many unfortunate
public utterances is there a line that
he could cross that you would decide you
couldn't support him i'm not i'm not
going to just speculate about what he
might say or what i might do but i think
it's pretty clear i've been very clear
publicly about
how i think you ought to change
directions and i hope that's what we're
going to see
that was another snippet of senate
majority leader mitch mcconnell speaking
betsy fisher martin and tammy haddad in
the latest episode of bloomberg politics
masters of politics podcast joining us
now to chat more about that conversation
is the one and only betsy fisher martin
herself um
so
yes
mitch mcconnell has been that's pretty
tough stuff throughout this whole
interview about trump are you surprised
the degree to which uh mcconnell has
kind of emerged as the kind of voice of
principle uh in this debate it's
interesting you say the word principle
because the way i have been thinking of
it is he's like the high school
principal
and
he has a senior class president that is
has the support of all the seniors and
he's a little bit nervous and the
teachers are a little bit nervous and
what does he do so he just i think is
just
sending the clear message
because it's important to him i think
ultimately and this is a person who is a
master of the senate this was his he
writes in his book how his ambition in
life was to be a senate majority leader
once he became a senator so keeping the
senate is
very important to him he became majority
leader he does not want to not be the
majority leader
so it's it's important to him that the
nominee
stick to the script stop the unfortunate
public utterances
and
prevail
did you think it was kind of
first of all there are two things that
were surprising one to me personally is
a that he did the interview because he's
sort of a you know a very cautious guy
but b
what he said is so on mitch mcconnell
because it there's an element of risk in
what he said about trump that he
basically you know has not a whole lot
of knowledge about issues that's
surprising at least to me to my ear well
i like i think his number one priority
is the future of the republican party i
did ask him that question if you could
choose if you had to choose between
winning the white house or the future of
the republican party what would you do
and he kind of caved out on that and
said well we can do both but at the end
of the day
i think he would not hesitate to throw
donald trump overboard if he needed to
in order to keep the senate well that's
the question i wanted to get to and
you've been around washington a long
time you have encountered people like
this in situations of all kinds as a
journalist over a long period of time
what's your gut saying he basically
left open the question of whether he
might unendorse donald trump do you
think that that's something that he
would actually conceivably do
i think so i think so and but i think
that it was important to him to issue
that warning and you know this is not a
washington gaffe where you say the truth
accidentally this was something very
deliberate and a message that he wanted
to send all right betsy fischer martin
thank you everybody in the entire world
should listen to the masters of politics
podcast on blooperpolitics.com this one
in particular but all of them will be
right back with who won the week
you